[Music]
hey Square I am not a square I think we
should invite Greg this weekend what's
this weekend
these people are hippies Rebels against
old-fashioned Authority I think these
kids need help they need is a bear
you're passing judgment on people you
know nothing about maybe that's why your
church is so empty when God walks in
here brings me a hippie I'll ask him
what it's all about because I do not
understand
his house is a very good Vine
[Applause]
[Music]
there is an entire generation searching
slow down this photo just in all the
wrong places if you want to reach my
people you need to speak to them in a
language they understand if I bring them
in someone who does my job I can only
walk through doors open to us in your
church that's a door that shut
you've probably noticed we have some
guests here today I'd like you to meet
my new friends welcome
that don't belong here half of the
morning wearing shoes they're saying the
new shag carpet they need our help
if you feel like you're misunderstood
and judged you will find forgiveness and
freedom right here that was awesome now
that door is open any time of day and if
there are some who don't like that well
then that door works both ways all right
Pastor let's begin I was almost done
with this but then you did what nobody
else would even dared
thing that we found I feel like I belong
you're gonna need a bigger Church
[Applause]
country is a dark and divided place but
now there's hope and it's spreading this
is your home and I want you to tell all
your friends about it
[Music]